[Music]
we we have another night tonight with
our wonderful friends the casbahs Center
for Advanced Study in the behavioral
sciences at Stanford this is the
twentieth talk it's now been it's little
over three years that we've had this
partnership we have three of our former
casbahs speakers here tonight we've got
at least one other or two other former
speakers here in the room and we always
love when our speakers come back so this
has been a great partnership and the the
best part about is the diversity we've
talked about technology environmental
subjects about psychology subjects that
the last one was about the Oxford
English Dictionary so take a look at
casbahs it is a remarkable institution
that's been around for over 60 years
based at Stanford and it is one of the
most important social science hubs
that's going on and they have been
historically important they will
continue to be and we're excited to have
the ongoing relationship so thank you
guys for being here tonight and and that
brings us on to tonight's speaker so
show Zeenat re Shaz and I have been
talking about this talk for months we've
been really warming this up for for a
long time you know she's been she's
gonna tell you about the the research
that she has been doing and then this is
one of those kind of dot-dot-dot talks
where it's less about we're not just
about reporting back research that has
concluded but about pointing to the
future and actually I think an exciting
opportunity for us to to be in dialogue
about where she's starting to go as
she's forming the path she's going to
take so and it's certainly one of the
most important subjects that is in the
world right now so I have this mangy
pile of books
here which are mostly from my personal
collection because we want you to think
about stories the stories that are
important to you we're gonna talk about
those stories we're going to talk about
how you know all those things I'm gonna
let her explain more about that but as
she's talking in the back of your mind
think about when does a story changed
your mind how do you feel about the
stories that you treasure the most and
and we'll get into that in Q&A please
have a big round of applause for Josie
Natori all right i'm super excited to be
here i'm hoping to sort of engage all of
you in this conversation that I've been
having mostly with myself in my own
brain so hopefully it's not gonna be
completely whacko so thank you so much
firstly to Michael for for not laughing
through this idea with me and sort of
encouraging it and nurturing it
hopefully it'll fly today so what I'm
gonna be talking to you about is fusing
facts and feelings to motivate action on
climate change a little bit about me so
you might not know who I am I grew up in
this place called Dubai it's not part of
Illinois I was once asked that it's
actually part of the Middle East it's in
this country called the United Arab
Emirates and this is what it looked like
when I was 10 so now you know how old I
am so um just stare at the screen for a
minute this is 1991 this is 2005 now
look at those four buildings right there
those haven't changed okay
well hopefully you're drinking and this
looks really cool and just go back and
forth a few times so why am i showing
this to you the reason I'm showing this
to you is because in a very short span
of time we can actually transform our
environment really really quickly I mean
this is amazing technology amazing
innovation amazing engineering it's also
to me growing up here it's very
difficult to sort of look at this and
sort of wonder way to the desert go you
know what happened to my landscape and
so they're building ski resorts in the
middle of the desert there are three so
far more designed to be both this is
what its gonna this is what its gonna
look like so it's kind of like an oil to
ice conversion this is sort of a the
Palmer's all resorts that you know
everyone gets beach access I mean who
doesn't love the beach so this is a
photograph I took and this was actually
my last visit to the UAE
it's very difficult for me to actually
go back because it doesn't feel doesn't
look like the place that I grew up in
and so this is a photograph that I took
from the shore of a ship dumping sand
into the ocean to make land and this is
how the the sort of the shoreline has
transformed over time this is 1973 1990
and 2006 so do you see the palm islands
and the world islands that's pretty
amazing right so in a very very short
period of time the entire environment
has completely transformed itself and so
this is where I grew up this is my
background so I came to the United
States in 2000 and I was at UIUC whoo
there are some alums we went to school
together and there they found me here
just amazing so did I study physics and
math and I was like alright
physics is amazing but I really wanted
to work on climate change I really
wanted to work on sustainability the
United Arab Emirates has like a very
high large environmental footprint so
does the United States and so the year
that I started my PhD was 2004 so I'm
sort of giving you the story of my life
and then I'm gonna embed
that into the story of the work that I'm
doing so in 2004 the the the same month
that I started my PhD this paper came
out in science magazine by pathala and
solo and like their first sentence in
their paper was alright humanity already
has all of the solutions we need to
solve the climate problem we don't have
to wait we have the technology we need
we can solve it today so humanity
already process we already has all of
these solutions so then why haven't we
done anything about it we still have
this problem happening right now so what
did they say in their paper so they said
all right this was sort of a
back-of-the-envelope exercise that they
did they said all right if we want to
stabilize emissions and then we want to
stabilize concentration let's just think
about it in terms of a variety of
technologies a variety of things we can
do so they said all right imagine each
of these technologies providing a wedge
a sort of a one Giga ton of carbon
decrease per year everything from
efficiency and conservation renewable
electricity carbon capture and storage
for like reforestation nuclear energy
biomass fuel switching so on and so
forth and this is just to stabilize
emissions and then after that we need to
actually decrease our emissions to net
removal so they sort of put forward this
entire portfolio I said great why aren't
we doing that stuff and what they also
said in their paper is improvements in
efficiency and conservation offered the
greatest potential to solve this problem
so I started dedicating my entire career
from then from that point on to figuring
out why is it that we don't incorporate
efficiency and conservation in our life
and I've been focusing primarily in the
United States so what's been going on as
you can tell our carbon dioxide
concentration which is basically how
much carbon dioxide there is in the
atmosphere has been going steadily up so
it just keeps increasing every year so
every year that I teach my course I have
to keep updating the numbers to keep
going up and it's like every time I
teach that one section of my class it's
like internal pay and I have to go home
and have my have myself a nice gin and
tonic at the end of the day it's like
you know how do we solve this so when Al
Gore sort of came up with the in
in truth he was trying to keep it under
400 parts per million so just as percent
is out of 100 parts per million is out
of a million so we're trying to keep
this at below doubling and we've just
passed 400 parts per million so that is
the challenge that we're faced today
so how do you visualize this in terms of
temperature so this is a beautiful
graphic that Edie Hawkings did is
basically a color map looking at what
does the average temperature look like
in the United States and each stripe is
one year so as you can tell if you just
squint from the back of the room it's
kind of going from bluish to reddish
right the folks at the back of the room
do you see that so that's basically
what's happening with our average annual
temperature so we're getting warmer so
in trying to figure out why we don't act
I actually asked 700 people across the
United States hey what is the single
most important problem for you today
what is the single most improper you in
the future
and what do you think is the world's
problem today and in the world's problem
in the future and here is the data and
this is data I collected in 2010 so the
most number one problem that America
faces today is the economy all right the
number one problem that the world faces
in the future is climate change
so the problem there is that the future
always happens in the future how do we
speed that [ __ ] up so how do we make the
future happen today and that's why I'm
sort of really interested in stories and
storytelling I'm really interested in
how do we compress time how do we make
time but how do we imagine what the
future is going to look like today
here's another challenge you guys have
probably seen this already again
very very difficult graphic what this
tells you is the percent of Americans
and this is data from the Gallup poll
saying that they worried about climate
change a great deal what you notice is
the more educated conservatives are less
likely to worry about climate change so
the more educated you are the less
likely you are to believe that this is a
problem and that this is something we
need to work on so this is a gap that we
really need to figure out how to bridge
you guys with me so far all right
but here's some here's something that
I'm working on is how again how do you
compress how do you compress time how do
you make the future happen today so as
as as Michael pointed out I'm at casbahs
this year and I asked 21 energy master
students at Stanford hey what is the
current energy mix for our current
energy system and what do you want the
future energy mix to look like ok so let
me walk you through the numbers so on
the first column an actual energy mix
this is what our actual energy
consumption mix looks like today so
that's the actual values our
participants do really well so they're
really accurate with how the current
energy mix is today so if you see for
example petroleum the current mix is 37%
our participants on average that 34%
really good yeah us just us and these
numbers won't add up to 100 because
these are row row averages yes but what
I really want to draw your attention to
is what they want the future energy mix
to look like okay so if put things that
are carbon-based in purple things that
are non-carbon-based in green so they
really want a huge decrease in our
carbon-based energy system and they want
a huge increase nuclear included in our
non-carbon-based system so that's great
so we have an image we have an idea of
what we want the future to look like now
the question is how do we transition to
that energy system how do we create a
transition decarbonisation pathway from
where we are today to where we need to
be so that's the first piece that I
wanted to show you so the question that
I would like to ask and this is where
storytelling comes into play
is what stories will you always remember
so I remember tons of stories from when
I was growing up in the Middle East and
then I still remember them today there's
some stories that have completely
transformed my life there some stories
that have completely shaped Who I am
and so what stories have changed your
thinking and behavior so this project as
Michael mentioned just started so I'm
going to show you some of the responses
have received from roughly 10 to 15
people who have talked to so far and I
can't really put this into a survey so I
tried putting this into a survey to send
to all of you
it doesn't make sense but if I ask you
something like what story has completely
transformed you right all of the
participants were just like looking at
the screen being like did you just
really ask them that's really hard so I
had to interview people to actually sort
of tease that out pull that out of them
out of their minds out of their mouths
so here are some examples the
dispossessed I just read this reread
this recently beautiful amazing saga of
different economic systems and what are
the pros and cons of them atlas shrugged
a lot of you know that when already the
writings of Abraham Lincoln like how
Lincoln sort of dealt with the Civil War
a special shout-out to Libra women
suffragists movement the matrix of
course the matrix neo looking very
handsome and Star Trek so these are sort
of the stories that people have told me
that has completely shaped them but for
different reasons so if you look across
these some of them are fiction some of
them are nonfiction some of them are
based in history some of them are not
and so they're what I'm trying to do is
distill elements of narrative that are
really really important and that are
have very strong contagion power and
then try to use that for the research
project that I'll be explaining to you
in a minute okay so I've started reading
this amazing book by Richard powers and
in his book he says the the best
arguments in the world won't change a
person mind the only thing that can do
that is a good story I kind of agree
with that because I've actually been so
I've been working on climate change
since 2004 and since this entire time
have been talking to lots of different
people and it's really hard just to show
data and show facts like the the slides
that I started off with with my talk
today that usually doesn't change
people's minds especially if their minds
are already made up so I think stories
are really important Neil Gaiman
actually gave a talk at the Long now and
he basically says all good stories
change you and I think that's really
powerful all good stories do changes but
sometimes we don't know how they changed
us and sometimes the change takes place
like way way way into the future so I'm
trying to figure out how to deal with
that so people don't act in terms of how
do you so what type of action and I'm
trying am I trying to get at
we need a price on carbon I think all if
all of us will agree with that we really
need a price on carbon right now and so
we need public support for a price on
carbon and Washington state a strike
starting to do that we need to change
individual behavior as well that
reflects our new transition pathway that
we're trying to get to and so a lot of
my past work has looked at facts and
feelings separately I've sort of kept
them separate and I've been toggling
between both of them because looking at
them together makes things really really
messy so what I've looked at is how do
people understand what is most effective
for them to change in their own lives so
if I were to ask you today what is the
single most effective thing you can do
to decrease your energy consumption
would you know do you want to shout out
some answers don't have kids yeah don't
eat meat don't fly don't fly electric
cars
food waste all right so we have a really
good list I'm going to show you what the
modal responses in the United States
you're gonna be really surprised and
then I've also been looking at how do
you change social norms how do you get
people to pay attention to this problem
because attention is actually a very
limited resource so think of attention
is like a very small pond of water that
you carry with you everywhere you go
and every time someone asks for
something you're like giving them a
little bit of that water and then you're
like oh my God where do my water go I
need to go and back into my cave so
that's what attention is it's just it's
a serious limited resource so I asked
you this question in your opinion what
is the most effective thing here are the
responses that we get since the 1980s
this has been the number one modal
response that people get people give to
this open-ended question what is the
single most effective thing the modal
response of starting with Willett
Kempton in the 1980s has been turning
off the lights and this is when you ask
people very broadly hey what is the
single most effective thing very similar
to what I asked you
however a surprising finding for my work
that I'm not gonna show you but I'll
talk to you about it for a second is if
you ask people what is the single most
effective thing other Americans can do
do you know what the answers are all of
the ones that you told me
so carpooling getting an efficient cargo
getting an electric car biking instead
of driving so the answers really change
so it's not that people don't know what
is effective is that they don't want to
do those behaviors themselves I'm
telling you more challenges and
solutions so turning off the lights is
great please do that but it's not the
most effective thing yeah you guys you
guys know already so I also you know
given my training in physics and in
engineering I was really interested in
how do people quantitatively estimate
how much energy different appliances use
so if I were to ask you do you know what
the difference is between a watt and a
watt hour do you guys know you guys know
okay two hands went up
do you guys know yeah three hands went
up okay all right a couple of guys in
the back and there's a friend's thing
yeah he knows but okay they're all
pointing at each other so a lot of
people do not know what a watt and a
watt hour is right so they don't know
about the units of energy are so what I
wanted to understand is if I were to ask
people about different appliances in
their homes how well do that can they
understand how much energy different
appliances use just broadly so what I
first had to do and over here on the
y-axis you have perceived energy used or
saved in watt hours and on the x-axis
you have actual energy used or saved in
watt hours and this is a log-log scale
so it goes from 110 hundred so on and so
forth so data that lies along the
diagonal line means people's perceptions
match reality okay so what I said was
all right imagine a hundred watt light
bulb a hundred watt light bulb being
left on for an hour uses a hundred units
of energy now how many units of energy
would your dishwasher use would you guys
be able to kind of yeah in the same
amount of time in one hour so that was
like the type of question I ask people I
would I want but I won't put you on the
spot I'll just show you the data
so I I told everyone all right 100 100
watt light bulb uses a hundred units of
energy how many units of energy with
these different appliances use so in
general the orange line is the overall
curve but I'm gonna walk you through it
with some examples so a laptops are
overestimated by a factor of two so
people think it's equivalent to one
light bulb when it's actually equivalent
to half and this is data from 2009 so
now laptops are becoming way way way
more efficient changing the washer
setting from hot to cold actually is
underestimated by a factor of 40 so
people think changing from hot to cold
is equivalent to saving one light bulb
when it's actually equivalent to saving
40 lightbulbs so this is the entire set
of appliances that we looked at and so
what you notice is that when you start
using a lot of energy when you start
thinking about appliances that use a lot
of energy there's a huge underestimation
a lot of this data is below the diagonal
line not just that people are not able
to correctly differentiate between these
appliances so there's this compression
bias so what we really need to do if we
are thinking about energy use is we need
to take that curve and pull it up
towards the diagnol how do we make
people accurate then there's the other
question which I hope you guys will ask
me is that does accuracy matter if we
have limited effort and I would say yeah
it does if people think that you know
some of these ineffective behaviors are
really effective and they're not that's
really problematic so what we does
anyone have accurate perceptions so we
asked this is disclaimer - we asked -
electrical engineers and they're really
accurate
so engineers yeah we're awesome so
engineers do really well on this task
and so what we did was we tested a
manufactured heuristics let me walk let
me break that down and what that means a
heuristic is basically a rule right so I
can give you a rule to enact a
particular behavior a manufactured
heuristic is a manufactured rule that I
give you to use when you're making a
decision so if I were to tell you large
appliances that heat and cool use a lot
more energy than you think that actually
is a heuristic that if you're making
your energy estimates that actually
pulls that curve up towards the diagonal
so I'm not teaching you what the
difference is between watts and what
hours I'm not telling you how to compute
how much energy different appliances use
I'm just giving you a very simple rule
what we so that's what the heuristic
condition is right here so you can see
the baseline basically replicates the
original data the heuristic condition
bumps the slope up and then if I give
you multiple anchors so I just gave one
light bulb in the first condition but if
I were to give you like an LED and I get
an I were to give you a dishwasher that
actually helps you gearshift between
these different appliances so that
actually improves your perceptions a lot
so there are ways that we found that
actually are able to correct people's
misperceptions of energy use sort of
circumventing teaching people basic
energy physics you guys with me so far
yeah okay great so using this idea of a
manufactured heuristic this is what I'm
proposed this is what I propose to do
with this new fellowship that I just
received and I'm super excited about it
that's why I want to tell you about it
what I'm planning to do is create a
library of politically politically
feasible policies that we can use to
stabilize our co2 concentration in the
United States and in the world I want to
then take those policies and distill
them into heuristics and then once I
distill them into heuristics I want to
embed them into narratives and see
whether there's going to be uptake and
transmission
all right so I need I need your help
with this because this is really really
hard so I sort of came up with this idea
of emotional and cognitive scaffolding
because the thing is some narratives
stay with us and some don't so the idea
of just a scaffold is basically
providing us with something that we can
hold on to such that when we face a new
situation we still have that scaffolding
that we can hold on to in order to
change our behavior in order to redirect
our behavior so that's what I'm also
trying to look at is what what are the
different features of narratives that
provide this emotional and cognitive
scaffolding for us that we can hold on
to and grapple with so that's the charge
for this new Carnegie fellowship that
I'd like your help with and that's what
I'm sort of looking at so I'm trying to
fuse facts and feelings and why do I
want to fuse facts and feelings because
I think you need both
I think feelings without facts it's kind
of like religion without science I think
one without the other they're really
interdependent and I think one without
the other is either lame or blind
you can pick so I need to figure out how
do I feel about the situation what is
the intensity of that feeling and then I
need to figure out what should I do
about that situation and what is my call
to action like what should I be doing so
right now the huge problem is is that we
have and very embedded narrative that
basically tells us that individuals do
not matter that none of us are we all of
us are just drops in the bucket but what
we don't realize is that these drops can
add up especially when it comes to
policy support and we've actually seen
that recently with the whole child
separation issue in the United States so
that's sort of my that's why I think
fusing facts and feelings is important
there are lots of books that have sort
of been uncovering by talking to people
that have mattered to them that actually
do a somewhat good job of fusing facts
and feelings so the lorax some of you
guys might have read them read Silent
Spring before the flood was a
documentary The Day After Tomorrow
Inconvenient Truth so on and so forth an
inconvenient truth actually is really
powerful like I I was actually surprised
by this so when I watched it I felt like
alright this convinced me that this was
there was a problem but I didn't know
what to do
about it and in the first in the first I
haven't seen that the most recent one
but in the first one
Al Gore only told us about what we could
do in sort of the ruling credits and I
thought that yeah this was an amazing
movie amazing platform and what I found
was with some of the more recent
research coming out is that not only did
it change some people's opinions about
climate change and it increased
knowledge and concern willingness to
reduce greenhouse gases and it actually
increased it first the purchase of
offsets within a 10 mile radius but that
actually decreased very quickly after
the movie was aired so this is sort of
one example of a narrative that has
somewhat changed the way people feel
about the issue but I think we can
actually go a lot more deep deeper into
the problem especially if we infuse
storytelling so I actually visited
Bishop has anyone been to Bishop Wow
so you guys have seen the Bristlecone
pine trees yeah okay so amazing amazing
place it's almost like a akin to sort of
a spiritual experience that I've ever
experienced so these these trees are
called the Bristlecone pine trees and
they're some of the oldest trees in the
world some of them go up to 5,000 years
old and so Richard going back to Richard
powers he basically says that they're
generally three levels of conflict
within a person between people and
between people and the environment and
so how do we deal with these different
levels of conflict do we need different
narratives or do we need different
features of narratives that can deal and
attack these different levels of
conflict so for example just to make it
pretty clear you know I've actually
decreased my flying quite a bit but it
actually I haven't been back home to
India and like maybe three and a half
four years now and it's like kind of
high time even my fat either that or my
family is gonna disown me so it's so
that's my battled within a person like
you know I'm trying to figure out how do
I keep my goal of decreasing my carbon
footprint active with my goal of also
having a good healthy family balance
thing battle between people is how do I
deal with what others are doing so let's
say if I decrease my carbon footprint
and other people around me don't how do
we deal with that
and the battle between people and non
people is basically how do I value
things that don't have a voice and I
think that that's really really
important so as we know the Bristlecone
pine trees are actually going to be
harmed under climate change they have
survived so so so long and that's really
really challenging for even people like
me who don't get to see them very often
and so how do we figure out ways
narratives that can help us understand
that that can help us sort of give us an
anchor to hold on to hold on to that
this also sort of brings me to back sort
of full circle to Neil Gaiman who
actually said the way a story can
survive is actually by by using by
surviving multiple at least three
generations so you need to tell the
story you need your kids to tell the
story and you need your grandchildren to
tell the story and so the question is
what are the features of narratives that
we can use that allow that type of
transmission especially when it comes to
climate change so what makes a narrative
memorable how do I figure out what are
the components of emotional and
cognitive scaffolding and we need
implementation plans so people really
like plans right so a WeightWatchers it
works
having people stop smoking it works so
we need implementations plan
implementation plans for our restricted
carbon budget as well especially when it
comes to changing changing the
collective belief about what we need in
terms of moving forward so the
challenges are the deep narratives might
actually take time to influence behavior
so if you think about some of the deep
narratives in your life you might have
read it as a kid and then you might be
acting on it now so it's really hard to
experimentally measure test especially
going back to cognitive science and
psychology it's really hard to actually
measure and test that so we need to
figure out ways to do that we need to
move beyond selling a specific policy
but why we need climate policies more
broadly and we need to figure out how to
bridge this growing partisanship that I
showed you earlier and so this is my
last slide and I'm hoping for a really
rich discussion but before that I wanted
to tell you a few more things I'd like
to know what moved what stories have
moved you stayed with you transformed
you what
the features of that story that has sort
of made it really sticky and very
visceral for you what are the features
of the narrative that can provide
scaffolding how do we stitch
manufactured heuristics into powerful
narratives do you guys have examples or
ideas for me and the few things that I
want to leave you with is that you know
I got to speak with Kim Stanley Robinson
who Michael talked about earlier I'm
sort of putting my hand on the Bible as
butcher Kim Stanley Robinson a little
bit earlier and he sort of explained to
me why we like narrative so much why we
like fiction so much and his explanation
which I think is a really powerful one
is that in one life we get to live
10,000 lives like as the more you read
the more you get to experience other
people's shoes other people's insights
the more you get you can grow grow
empathy the other challenge is that
there's sort of two more points that I'd
like to talk to you about
we're both villains and heroes in the
story so moving beyond Joseph Campbell's
sort of the monomyth where which where
it's just one hero on this sort of
singular journey and we move forth we're
sort of we are the villains because
collec we're collective villains and we
could be potential collective heroes so
how do we design a story that has
multiple players and then finally I've
been thinking a lot about this which is
the power of utopia versus dystopia so
there are lots of climate communicators
that sort of keep showing dystopian
images of what the future is going to
look like and I think that's really
negative I think that's really harmful
for effective communication because that
actually leads to the ostrich effect and
this that's what it's actually called
where the person receiving that
information just digs in and puts their
head into the sand and so how do we pull
that out by both showing what the
dystopia is and how do we prevent that
by painting another picture of a utopia
and so with that I would like to thank
you for your attention and you guys are
great and thank you Michael for inviting
me
[Applause]
gonna see we're gonna thank you so much
as that's great we're gonna chat a
little bit get your questions ready and
miles or you are you handy I've got a
I've got a question for miles so so make
sure he gets a mic I'm giving you a five
minute warning so it doesn't count as
putting it on the spot that was yeah
seems easy
yeah easy enough all set we'll wrap it
up here tonight and should be done how
do you keep your drive going and
enthusiasm when you see challenging
stats and challenging responses from
some of these things what's your alright
are you yeah is it is it he said
optimism is it stubbornness is it what's
how do you characterize how you keep
your drive for this so up and call
stubborn by both students and
collaborators at the floor know that's a
really good question so I guess a way to
reframe the question is why do I work on
climate change so I think that this is
sort of a we're at the we're at sort of
where the the paths diverge in the
forest and humans have this ability to
see a problem and solve it we've done
that multiple times in the past and so I
have a deep belief that we can solve
this even though we haven't as yet and
that's what drives me is that I I love
people too much I just vomited a little
bit on my own on my own comment sorry
he's really bad do you think we can
solve it because we're so damn smart or
because we're gonna get afraid at some
point or what do you know I mean do you
think about it that far what what do you
think is the wet what capacity
some of these trajectories do you think
so here's here's what where I fall so
we've we've actually I'm actually just
coming out of a couple of conferences
we've been talking to lots of people
about this including Sai foo and a
meeting at Livermore and some other
meetings and and to be honest I think
that we've had the technology for a long
time so there's still a lot of people
that keep saying oh we just need better
battery technology we just need you know
better nuclear technology we just dot
dot dot and so we've had the technology
for a long time and I'm not saying
technology doesn't matter I'm saying
that we've had that I think what we need
is a deeper emotional connection with
the problem so that we can act on it
because if the future is always
happening in the future no matter what
technology well no matter what
technologies we have now unless we sort
of internalize this externality of
carbon dioxide we're not going to act
and so it's not about cleverness I think
it's actually about the ingenuity
completely embedded with the emotional
capacity of why we should be acting when
you it was interesting when you showed
the first images of boiled ice the ski
resort yeah yeah it made me think of the
Michael Pollan's
narrative around so and and it's
interesting because as you've asked us
all to think about the stories that have
changed us or the way one of the ways I
think about is have set facts in my head
that I then have used ever since then
actually it was his long now talking us
before I was working a lot with long now
but I saw him talk about it and he he
makes the explanation of you know this
of the corn and oil and the release of
everything and and it just doesn't make
sense and the bad environmental
decisions around the large-scale
industrial farming what I so so to
connect that to and I wore my neil
gaiman mirror master tonight
for me yeah and for Neil himself so what
when I reflect on that and what our goal
here is and I think about so-so Neil
talks about the viral aspect story talks
about stories being alive and in a way
they're using us to to stay alive longer
where we're really just vehicles to keep
stories going
the lesson I learned I kind of keep to
myself I may talk to some people about
it it doesn't have the virality in every
sense that a better story does so in a
way I kind of keep it my might sell that
a little bit say it a little bit to
people but there are other stories
legends things that whatever the the
sweetness of it is that I think become
more social and propagate more do you
think of something like because it
because there's a question of like are
we talking about education or
storytelling because education but it
seems like education may stay with the
individual and not propagate as quickly
as that I don't know my do you think
that's is that a useful way to think
about so I think I mean I'm talking to
sort of a roomful of communicators I
think if you're a really effective
communicator you're probably using some
stories right and so I think
storytelling allows people to imagine a
journey but in general scientists seem
like they're less comfortable using
storytelling as a method of
communication especially in the
classroom
but I've also been experimenting with
that more recently and of course that I
teach at Indiana University called human
behavior and energy consumption where
students want to hear the story I mean I
started today's talk with the story of
me growing up in a completely foreign
land you know and so I think that makes
information more sticky as opposed to
just the facts but there are people that
are just the facts ma'am kind of people
and they don't necessarily want to use
storytelling in the same way that I'm
proposing so that's a great segue
actually the question
I want to ask Myles so Myles Traer spoke
for us before he is a geologist at
Stanford and a science communicator of
some note Myles I want to ask you and
I'm not I'm doing this I'm doing this to
put you on the spot but I'm doing this
not to promote what you did but to ask
you why you did what you did why did you
do what you do so you've done you've
done two projects that have that are fun
and that are that are interesting at
about climate I'm just gonna summarize
them real quickly and I want you to tell
us how did how did that happen and what
kind of effects you had one is you
extrapolated the geological history of
the game of Thrones world and that
started conversations of some sort and
I'd like to know what those work and the
other is you look at the carbon
footprint of super-heroes
so you took known superheroes we all
know and said is Wonder Woman worser
than the flash worser than the Batmobile
the show so so did you have were you
just doing that for fun did you actually
did and so what was your intention and
and and what kind of outcomes do you
have how helpful good feedback for us on
that okay there's a lot there's a lot in
there um so one of the reasons they are
one of the the best methods that I found
in doing projects like this or in
producing a podcast called generation
Anthropocene or doing any of this work
is that the stories are better when
they're made personal and Shazza said
that tonight multiple times you know you
feel it more when it resonates with the
things that you already care about and
so I am a nerd to the nth degree and so
yes I love Game of Thrones and yes I've
been reading comics and love superheroes
and it meant a lot to me and when I
connected something like climate change
or you know geological history which is
a way of sort of compressing time you
know how do we understand millions of
years you know try to imagine a million
anything know right my brain just sort
of melts but if I can connect it to
something that I'm already in love with
something that I already care about
I found that it actually works really
well and so with Game of Thrones it was
you know the conversations that came out
of that were hilarious to me well you
know where people were saying you know
like you need to know anything about
geology if this thing is really fun when
I was like I care a lot about you care
more about geology than Game of Thrones
but people still seem to love it and
people still seem to care about and they
would ask these questions about like
wait a minute you know what causes an
ice age you know wait what how are you
interpolating a climatic history from
the rocks yeah you know it's cool it's a
it's this amazing science that we can do
and with the carbon footprint of
super-heroes it was the same way I mean
that story began with me sitting around
a campfire and someone asking me what my
favorite superhero was and I said Batman
and after heated conversation said Myles
you're a hypocrite you're an
environmentalist Batman's got to be
terrible and rather than laughing I was
like I bet I could calculate that but it
was it was that moment of like I I
immediately saw the project there cuz I
want I love this I care about this if I
love this and I care about this and
there's clearly box-office records that
suggest that a huge part of the world
that was and cares about this if I can
connect that in any way to this other
thing that I also love and care about
which is climate change that that will
make a huge impact so that that was
basically the why of why I put those
things together Thank You Myles thank
you
you have any thoughts a clan that I mean
there's there's emotion there there's so
it's it's it's communicating through
your love and you know you find the
people that are nerding on the same
thing your nerding on or or i mean is
this is some of that helpful to to the
path that you're on I highly recommend
you check out miles of websites I have
the really nerdy and really great I was
kind of surprised with how bad Batman's
carbon footprint was it's so I guess
this is this is sort of a question for
the audience right I mean if you're not
really into comic book heroes that's not
gonna really appeal to you and so I'm
looking at you know when I think about
reading like you know there's some of
ursa Lola Gwynn's books that actually
paved the way for JK Rowling to write
Harry Potter and people don't know about
that work but they love Harry Potter so
I'm trying to understand what is the
landscape and fabric that make things
really sticky and I think that for a
certain audience like that is amazing
you know the like the like people really
do engage with the carbon footprint of
superheroes because that's such an
innovative amazing sort of way to
conceptualize carbon footprints and it's
fun I am trying to also figure out like
I think so using that first specific
audience this is awesome but I think
what we also need to do is figure out
methods that we can use more broadly
with people who you know are ly hostile
writes about in strangers in their own
land like how do we sort of appeal to
the Conservatives that I talked about
who are more educated like the more
educated they are the less likely they
are to believe that this is a problem so
they're sort of digging their heels in
and so one so so an idea that we've been
talking about at casbahs is to figure
out ways to allow people to save face
when they're extracting themselves from
a position that they've all read ugh
themselves into and that's really hard
but I mean but there are people working
on it
yeah well thank you for your talk
tonight I well one I want to answer one
of your questions and the story that
moved me the most was dune and you look
at this you know highly extreme
environment where they were and they
were doing environmental I mean there
was this kind of world ecologist who was
the most powerful scientist in a way the
most powerful person on Arrakis right
who because the environment was so
extreme the environmental science became
this just you know absolute that
everyone had to answer to and I think
actually as we do things like try and go
to Mars and people say well why would go
to Mars my take is if you can terraform
Mars
you can terraform our planet pretty darn
well right and then the amount of carbon
there is a lot more right so like let
them try that's awesome so that the
failing technology of Mars will do well
here so I think extreme environments are
a really good motivator and I was I was
I was touched a little bit by what you
said about the distance between
childhood and adulthood and the way that
we really change our opinions and I
think that's a that's a very key thing
and I'll I remember talking to a
designer from GM who was designing
sports cars and he said we designed for
eight-year-old boys because they're
gonna buy them when they're 40 and that
was a you know it's a kind of a silly
anecdote but like if you take it to
heart like this the people who buy the
sports cars right so you you know you
actually are designing for the
eight-year-olds and if you change the
eight year olds it's only thirty more
years thank you sorry Thanks
I I wonder if in fact we should be
aiming stories that are very very narrow
audience and the little bit of work I've
done on this is we should aim our
stories at bankers
because if we can create a narrative if
that resolving climate change gives them
forty and a hundred year investment
returns the problem is solved and if we
cannot we're just fooling ourselves
mm-hmm and so what should we know in
fact we focusing all of our effort which
by the way involves public persuasion of
the bankers the kids of the bankers the
cousins of the bankers need to be
persuading the bankers persuade the
bankers and then the government's will
follow mm-hmm because that's how
apartheid the bankers persuade bankers
and then the problem solves itself
mm-hmm so I'd like to I'd like to
respond to that so I think one thing
that our community is actually
struggling with right now is that it's
our response to climate change is really
haphazard like there are lots of
different groups that are sort of moving
towards a goal but we don't have a clear
sense of what that goal is so if you
talk to most economists if not all
economists they all want just a price on
carbon so I've actually been
interviewing at casbahs a bunch of
economists including George Shultz who's
gonna be visiting here and some other
people who are working at hedge funds
and they all I mean the group that I'm
interviewing they all believe that
climate change is happening a huge
problem and a price is just gonna solve
it but the challenge there is that we've
been talking about a price on carbon
since the 1980s so we've been talking
about that for a really really long time
but we haven't had a simple price on
carbon in the United States and the
price on carbon that we've had in
British Columbia actually it's it's
great but because of the boom in natural
gas that actually led to increased
emissions so I think so I think that
that just focusing on one I mean and and
I'm gonna get back to them just focusing
on your audience so I think focusing on
one strategy is probably not the best
solution I think we do need a price but
we need a whole bunch of other things as
well going back to just focusing on
bankers I'm not I mean I'm you know that
might be how apartheid worked
um in terms of solving that problem but
I'm not sure I'm not sure if that's
gonna work here and here's here's my
hesitation so some of the some of the
folks in the banking community the hedge
fund investment community that I've been
talking to you know they were so excited
that a lot of these large oil companies
are being sued by different states but
most recently the judge basically said
hey listen I believe in climate change
but I'm throwing this lawsuit out
because it just doesn't make sense to
sue somebody based on you know past
crimes that were all of you know that
were related to climate change so that
kind of worries me because if if we're
only focusing on one community and
putting all of our eggs into the banking
basket what if what if that doesn't work
so for example like not thinking about
banking but just looking at insurance
companies insurance companies are all on
on top of climate change they're using
like the best latest greatest models for
sea level rise and adaptation because
they want to price insurance correctly
and I think that's great and so they're
already using it but they're kind of
using it to their advantage and so I'm
not sure that's sort of a very very
long-winded answer to saying I'm very
hesitant to putting all of my eggs into
one audience basket please all the
questions unfortunately but we really
want and I'm easy to find very there's
only one person with this name that's me
make sure you crowd around we like to
see a mob around so are any of the
states in the Gulf region addressing
climate change in any substantive way
given that the they both contribute
probably out of proportion to the two
emissions but are also very affected the
summertime temperatures even when I was
there were often in the 50s Celsius
that's a really good question
so they are doing some projects but they
I mean it's basically it goes back to
extreme environments right I mean you're
living in a really hot humid desert that
gets really really hot
in the summertime we have sort of two
climates like hot and hotter and so
energy use has gone down but if you look
at residential energy use over time it's
kind of like it's been increasing and if
you look at that against HDI which is
Human Development Index we're sort of
increasing our residential energy use in
terms of kilowatt hours per person per
year without that much improvement in
the Human Development Index and so there
are some projects and right now what's
really interesting about the UAE and I
can just speak about the UAE is that
they're they know that you know oil is
not going to be the future so they're
trying to reinvest in education and they
sort of have a whole amazing project
that's about going to Mars I'm
collecting really good weather data and
they're trying to sort of really expand
their scientific profile to trying to
plan to try to sort of make a stamp on
the world about where technology and
science is going but in terms of carbon
footprint yeah that that trend is still
pretty alive and inactive so off the top
of my head there are three examples of
country sized civilizations the United
Kingdom Denmark and California which is
by itself like the sixth largest economy
in the world which have made wedge to
your carbon wedge wedge scaled progress
in reducing carbon change or in reducing
carbon emissions and in accomplishing
the goal that you are positing as a goal
you're trying to accomplish so I'd be
very curious to know number one how do
you incorporate the actual demonstrated
results of those civilizations in your
research and number two just why didn't
you mention it during your talk great
why didn't you mention France and Costa
Rica
what so um sorry just banter so yeah
those do lots of examples so let me talk
a little bit about I mean all of the
examples you mentioned and on top of
that France in Costa Rica as well so
I've been thinking a lot about those two
specifically let me tell you why
Costa Rica has said no to nuclear energy
right like just completely they don't
want any nuclear energy and they've
actually demonstrated I think a
continuous 300 days last year of just
have it supplying the entire energy for
the entire country from renewables
that's amazing 300 days like non-stop
with current technology France is also
amazing they've had really low carbon
footprint and sorry low carbon emissions
because most of their energy comes from
nuclear roughly 80 to 90 percent now
they're starting to increase their
carbon emissions because again natural
gas is starting to enter into the mix
Germany unfortunately has turned off all
of their nuclear power plants and now
they're just basically importing energy
in from France which indirectly is
coming from nuclear and so I think there
are actually lots of so there are
actually lots of examples like that and
even within the United States so I mean
like I teach a whole course on this so
even within the United States they're
really different examples about policies
passing in on the local level so
recently California passed the solar
solar cells on your roof plan that's
gonna basically for every new home
that's sold you're you're going to need
solar panels on your roof similarly Ohio
which is traditionally conservative also
passed a new rule on net metering so
they actually want to encourage
renewables into the market because they
know that it brings jobs so they're
doing these four really different
reasons and I think that your point is
really a very very valuable one which is
we really need to understand based on
local feeling emotion stories of what no
that's not your point can I just finish
the sentence so you need to really care
a lot about what the people are going
through on the ground and what has
shaped their perceptions for why they
allow specific policies to pass and
not others so in the United States we're
actually pulling much more nuclear
offline than building new nuclear online
and that's primarily driven by increases
in capital cost as well as nuclear risk
perceptions and so that's really
challenging because I don't think in the
lease in the near term in the next five
years we're going to get much in terms
of nuclear on even though lots of people
that I talk to in the nuclear space are
like all four modular reactors or molten
salt reactors and I'm like that's great
but I don't think we're gonna get those
technologies passed based on those two
realities that I told you did i roughly
answer your question the next question
is there are there resources you would
point folks are watching on livestream
folks are here to educate better what
are some really good resources and and
resources for us to look at and share
are there like online courses are there
just activist groups or anything for
good solid climate or energy consumption
information in this space any any
resources you would like to point out no
actually I'll be honest with you like if
you type into Google right now I mean
you can you have a phone if you type
into Google right now how to save energy
in your home you'll get lists of like
3000 things a hundred things three
things there's sort of not a very
unified clear message and they're all
different things everything so I also
study water and how do people use water
in both in the United States and in
other countries and we actually you know
there was a tweet that was retweeted by
the EPA that linked to a site that said
you should reuse your ice cubes to water
your plants as a way to save water and
so it's so-so no but but what this
highlights is that there's this huge we
need a concerted concerted effort to
sort of figure out what we need and I'm
not sure if I can I mean there's lots of
resources sister 350.org is Bill
McKibben's group Al Gore has a new
be out and Inconvenient Truth part 2
there are lots of policies so I read
climate wire and green wire energy wire
there's all sort of repositories for the
latest and greatest and research that's
happening the New York Times as an
amazing green I mean they have an
amazing group of environmental news
reporters Washington Post also does an
amazing job with with their with their
new staff with reporting on what's going
on and it's not so much a question but
maybe a comment and answer to your
question and for Jim Peters I don't know
close hold it closer things I don't know
if I can unpack all my thoughts but
trying to understand what you said I'll
do my best
I'm Josh Fox do you know who that is
Gasland closer thank you clearly I don't
do this very often um he I had the
opportunity to recently listen to a
story that he told it's performance art
that he's getting ready to put out into
different communities because he granted
he's focused on fracking he realizes
that the message isn't getting out and
in fact his message was tainted by
people saying you don't have the facts
you may have the feeling you're a funny
guy you can share stories but you don't
have the facts your facts aren't real
and what he tells in this story is about
how data mining and I can't even
describe it very well but how he was
basically smeared by the media based on
a number of different factors and I'm
wondering if I was thinking of your
facts and storytelling and I'm wondering
if one of the opportunities that we have
is to try and get to people that are
maybe non-believers of climate change
through one kind of celebrity and and a
lot of what people are interested in
today that maybe I don't know if they're
the uneducated or they're just just the
non-believers but get out there and tell
them stories that attract something
that's interesting in sort of a
celebrity way to get them to listen to
these things it really impacted me
I'm a person that goes I listen to all
these things I knew all the things I
should do I do some of them I don't do
all of them but I tried to influence
others to do that in my own way but I
wonder if that's something to consider
to think about what he's doing or maybe
even just connect with him to see what
he's doing because he's trying really
hard to influence and to impact this
sort of change
yeah and that's that's a great point
there's actually another group that's
housed at Stanford called the solutions
project and they're working with
Leonardo DiCaprio and Mark Ruffalo and
some other really famous fancy actors
and stuff like that and trying to get
people to sort of understand the message
yeah so they are our groups doing that
in the climate change space - and I know
he works mostly on fracking and natural
gas but I'll definitely try to connect
with him at some point test test test
okay hi so um first of all I was
interesting for me to see the women's
March up there because funny enough the
women's March in New York of the
suffragettes back then is has been used
for a story of the tobacco industry I
don't know whether you know but a lot of
the women have been given cigarettes and
that was the point when suddenly smoking
got really fashionable for independent
strong women
so this March has been used as an
advertising story basically as we know
now a very unhealthy advertising story
and the long-term so I was wondering but
Mike well this is just a story to tell
about my question was I was wondering
and this is maybe my European view and a
critical question whether it's really
the time today especially in this
political climate here in the US but
also in other countries in Europe more
and more to tell stories or is it isn't
it more the question the the situation
where we should really stick to reality
and teach people more to be realistic
about things and to Ricci the things
more as they are and to act on that and
and we shouldn't all our efforts be more
concentrated on that this is just a
question I'm having I don't know but I'd
I'd like to bring up this question
because I think it's a really important
question exactly
especially right now no I think that's a
great point the thing is for each for
each present where we are right now we
have sort of a multitude of futures that
we could potentially be on and so I
guess my question to you back would be
is there a particular future that I mean
is there a particular future that we
should focus on or so so imagine sort of
a cone that sort of goes out from where
we are today and even where we are today
is not just a point location it's sort
of multiple locations in a space and so
everything sort of widens out from that
and so we can we can talk about like all
of those different futures and I'm not
saying that we should I mean I mentioned
both dystopia and utopia I think
actually both especially in the next few
decades both are within our grasp and
some I'm not sort of saying that we
should paint a false future in any way
but I think that we should paint a
future that we should be in two
multitude of futures that are possible
based on what we change right now does
that make sense
no I think I think I really like what
you say that that's not the point I'm
just I just wanted to bring up the
general question whether it's something
I'm thinking about a lot myself and I
don't have an answer but I'm still
thinking about whether it's really the
time to create more narratives or more
stories or whether it's not the time to
really get back to realities because a
lot of politicians at the moment in a
lot of countries in this world are
telling a lot of stories which don't
have anything to do with our realities
or the realities of the people who vote
for them and so I'm wondering whether
it's really the right climate political
climate to bring up new stories or
whether we should get back to a new kind
of realism and so to say it's a it's
also philosophy Lusaka question yeah I
mean I think in some cases we have
narratives
talking about fences we're not just
talking about very details here we're
also talking about the story of it's
important for me to have an electric car
or it's important for me to think before
I buy certain things or go on a plan
that that being conscientious about it
so I don't know they're all like literal
fiction stories we're talking about here
I think we got time for one last
question we just take one last question
in and then please stick around and keep
the questions coming because she has one
sit keep the dialers going your last
question of the night thank you so much
for that talk it really I've been
thinking about these issues as well and
I think you've diagnosed the situation
pretty on point in terms of what we need
to do and how I need to catalyze this
planetary sort of we talked about
coherence as a term that we use in terms
of thinking about the culture so I was
wondering if you could go back a few
slides to the project that you're
working on sure I thought it was just
really a wonderful collection of
objectives to me this just makes me
optimistic to think that we could start
working on something like this and
together like have this very feasible
sense of like this as possible I guess I
was just wondering where are you in
terms of like putting this theory right
now you've been sort of in academia how
does this go from you know the ivory
tower to the grass roots how do we get
people actively making this happen sort
of thing why don't you sort of frame
with the Carnegie project is set your
part we'll meet back here in two years
and you'll tell us what so are you gonna
be based at Indiana through this are you
going
other places what's what's your or do
you know yet
no that's a both of these are sort of
great questions so I'm like really
really blessed to have this fellowship
that buy some of my time for a while to
solve those three problems up there and
so what I'm planning to do is I'm
planning to actually try to meet meet
and talk with people who are doing
grassroots works I've tried to connect
with the climate advocacy lab here I'm
talking with people who are working on a
much more different levels of
policymakers I'm trying to talk I mean
I'm just trying like right now I'm just
going abroad so the fellowship actually
starts in September so that's why I've
presented you with just the research
questions as opposed to anything that's
actual work done the second year I'm
planning to just travel so to sort of be
like a vagabond of sorts and trying to
leave I mean you're right I've been on
foot
[Laughter]
we could live stream it we could do a
whole thing of it my whole life but I
think that you're right I think I need
to connect with people outside of
academia and I've in an academic through
and through like I'm like straight up so
you might be familiar with David
Krakauer who's a molecular molecular
biologist turned complexity scientist
who has a great sort of notion that he
says culture is like a giant inception
event in the mind and so for me when I
think about this I feel like the future
is gonna be won and lost in the
battleground of culture and thinking
about that in the context of seating
these ideas and someone mentioned sort
of getting to the cultural figureheads I
feel like that's a really good approach
that glad that you have you know these a
good story to present them so that they
can start spreading the word work with
me
oh thank you
[Music]
how long now if challenge going for you
to remind you to seize the millennium
but start sooner please we really need
[Applause]
[Music]